foreign
David's in San Antonio hi David how are
you
I'm doing great thanks how are you today
better than we deserve how can we help
so I've uh got a couple questions first
one I'm I'm getting close to finishing
baby step two
um I can see the Finish Line it's maybe
weeks or even a couple of months away
um I've been doing the baby steps I
guess for about three years now I didn't
even know I was doing them uh I've also
been saving as well and I'm ready to
move to baby step three but I'm just
scared okay
um I admit I do still use a couple of
credit cards but I pay them off in full
every month uh I know you're not a big
fan of credit scores but I'm rocking
about 800. I don't care I had a
okay
you said you know I'm not a fan I really
don't I know I know
um I had a couple of expensive trips
over the summer most of it's paid for I
have one last credit card bill due David
you were doing nothing we teach why are
you asking Our advice
well
um here's the thing
um I've got about
uh I have a student loan to the tune of
about 6 300 and change
um now I have five thousand dollars in
treasury bills and I just moved that
over to my savings account down the
street at my credit union with what I
had in there already I'm sitting on
about 8 800 in liquid cash okay
um so so take a trip
I got the money uh do I take a trip or
do I just drop a nuclear bomb on my
student loan and my credit card and be
done with it
I mean what do you think what do you
think we might say
I'm pretty sure I know what you're going
to say you do know David you know what
we're gonna say David David
um during my savings come on David don't
play yourself
you know I mean I'm gonna I will drain
my savings and I can rebuild it I mean
I'm I've you definitely can read it I
make enough to put money away every
month how much do you make but I'm just
uh I'm working two jobs right now
combined about 48k okay
um I am applying for for another job
um and I'll sarcasm aside I am really
curious why when you don't do anything
else we say do you care what we think
that is a good question you seem to be
an authority on this so well I know but
but I'm an authority on the other stuff
you're doing and you weren't doing it
and you knew that and so I'm I'm not
trying to be mean I mean you kind of
have to decide who you is
you know and fair enough okay and so
um I I don't mind it doesn't offend me
I'm gonna go on with my life you're
going to go on with yours so we'll still
be friends you know I love you I'm glad
your life is good but the if you pick
and choose on the buffet of what we lay
out in front of Ramsay all the Ramsay
things and you pick and choose you
really you could almost get yourself in
trouble because you sort of do it sort
of do this sort of do that sort of do
this and then all you know you're you
know you're gonna run those credit cards
back up statistically yeah there's a 90
chance you're gonna go back in credit
card debt because you still honestly
think a credit score is a good thing
because you're proud of it you still
honestly think while you've got this
debt that it's okay to travel
you still honestly are wondering whether
you ought to cash out your savings and
put it towards it those are honest
discussions in your head but I can just
tell you from from having done this for
30 years where the all of those things
are going to lead you and you can't just
do one of them and keep doing the other
two or three
and end up in a good place dude and we
love you too much to not tell you the
truth so
um you'll be wondering I really would
not pay off your debt with this money
unless you're going to cut up your
credit cards and start living on less
than you make
and plug in responsibility to the whole
thing if you're not going to do the
whole thing please don't do just a
little of it it could bring you harm